tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
nouvelle journée de faiblesse pour le
franc mais rattrapé par un redressement
en fin de journée le point avec emmanuel
de la taille
après que valéry giscard d'estaing est
préconisé de nouveaux rapports entre la
france et l'algérie
le point sur les relations actuelles
entre les deux pays par gérard saint
paul cas de conscience pour les
australiens
doivent-ils exploiter et exporter leur
uranium
un reportage de notre envoyé spécial
régis faucon la cgt en perte de vitesse
aux élections professionnelles la
désunion de la gauche y est sans doute
pour quelque chose françois go fusillade
à boulogne sur scène après un hold up
avec otage les policiers abattent deux
bandits et arrêtent un de leurs
complices
bonsoir le froid depuis le début de
février c'est un peu le régime de la
douche écossaise
un jour froid comme le temps une
amélioration une petite rechute un
rattrapage et cetera et cetera le tout
sous un déluge tout de même permanent de
polémique électorale
aujourd'hui par exemple ce matin le
franc avait commencé à faiblir l'après
midi il récupère notamment après que la
banque de france et relever le loyer de
l'argent à 10 et demi pour cent le
dollar après avoir atteint 491 est ainsi
redescendu au niveau d'hier soit 4
francs 88 avec emmanuel de la taille
nous avons vu dès le départ que cette
courbe en dents de scie pouvait durer au
gré des sondages électoraux jusqu'en
mars et qu'elle était donc dangereuse
pour une spéculation qui reste
d'ailleurs extrêmement prudente le point
maintenant à la fin de cette semaine de
soubresauts sur notre monnaie est venue
de la taille les robes vous électoraux
du franc a ont été marqués par une
certaine disproportion entre la tempête
d'invectivés politiques et des marchés
certes nerveux mais sans aucune panique
ce qui rappelle certaines vérités
élémentaires en maths
endemol primo la valeur du franc est un
double impératif vital car c'est ce qui
pousse des épargnants petits et grands à
investir ou non dans l'économie et
comment de la valeur du travail national
pour payer les importations 2% de moins
sur le franc s'est faite milliards de
plus sur nos importations
un peu plus que l'impôt sécheresse
secundo la force d'une robe d'une
monnaie repose essentiellement sur la
politique économique présente et future
la fameuse confiance de large la droite
la paire souvent mais la gauche c'est
bien qu'elle ne l'a jamais nulle part
d'avancées douala mérité et la confiance
de l'argent au delà des slogans c'est
là-bas des chefs d'entreprise aux
collègues du bureau qui cherchent à
protéger ses petites économies
tertio quand une monnaie est attaqué le
plus sûr moyen de sombrer et de riposter
massivement ce qui donne l'impression de
panique ou de verrouiller les contrôles
réflexe bien français ce qui n'empêche
jamais l'argent de filet mais à coup sûr
de revenir la souricière le contrôle des
changes c'est le signe même de lentilles
confiance l'essentiel c'est la politique
suisse enfin la spéculation actuelle
vient avant tout les entreprises
françaises et étrangères qui se
protègent contre des lendemains
électoraux
il n'y a aucun affolement chez les
particuliers qui se demandent simplement
souvent sans réponse
s'il faudrait acheter un peu d'or déjà
très cher ou des ombres a indexé sur
l'or ou les deux le danger de la crise
électorale
ce n'est pas que le franc ne remonte pas
après une baisse c'est qu'il ne récupère
pas tout le terrain perdu en effet à
linverse des fausses rumeurs du style
économiquement il faudrait une bonne
dévaluation la france aurait besoin pour
longtemps d'un franc plus fort financer
l'expansion et l'emploi que le bon sens
ne déserte pas la france mais qu'au
contraire le bon sens s'y installe en
force
cette formule du président de la
république a été très reprises dans la
presse aujourd'hui à propos de
l'interview qu'elle a donnée hier soir à
cinq confrères pour les télévisions la
question portait vous le savez sur la
politique étrangère de la france
et c'est dans sa conclusion qu'il a
répondu sur le point de savoir si le
résultat des prochaines élections
pourraient avoir des conséquences sur
notre politique étrangère
évidemment a répondu le président le
choix des français aura des conséquences
importantes notamment sur la réputation
et l'action de la france il ya deux
points forts
dans cette émission il ya eu deux points
forts l'algérie et la politique
française du désarmement
l'algérie avait déjà été un des thèmes
de sa précédente intervention à la fin
de l'année dernière c'était le jour où
on apprenait que les otages du polisario
serait libérée et c'était georges
marchais qui l'avait annoncé à alger
les journalistes avaient constaté à ce
moment là que les rapports s'étaient
beaucoup détériorées entre paris et
alger
et pourtant on avait pu croire qu'il
devait se normaliser
hier soir le président a tenu à regarder
a reparlé de l'algérie il serait
souhaitable at-il dit que nos rapports
soit bon il faudrait définir un nouveau
cadre de relations
les accords d'evian ne correspondent
plus à la réalité à ces fameux accords
d'evian prélude à une solution
algérienne nécessaire mais ô combien
pénible nous les avons tous en mémoire
faisons le point sur ce passage des
déclarations du président avec vos
gérard saint paul ya le président
giscard d'estaing a d'abord rappelé
combien les relations franco algériennes
sont difficiles depuis 1962 d'abord
parce que l'accession à l'indépendance a
été douloureuse et cela des deux côtés
de la méditerranée depuis le moindre
incident technique le moindre incident
de parcours devient contentieux
politiques entre la france et l'algérie
entendant ces propos hier soir les
journalistes qui avaient suivi le voyage
du président de la république en algérie
le 12 avril 1975 qui avait vu pendant
trois jours les couleurs françaises et
algériennes flotter côte à côte sur
alger et vécu l'accueil populaire de
l'ancienne rue michelet ne pouvait
s'empêcher de se dire que ce temps là
est bien loin déjà c'était le premier
voyage d'un président français là-bas
depuis l'indépendance le président
houari boumédiène avait même accepté le
principe d'une invitation officielle en
france d'où vient cet actuel malentendu
en partie selon le président giscard
d'estaing d'un cadre juridique qui n'est
plus adapté à la situation franco
algérienne d'aujourd'hui
ce cadre juridique est en effet
constitué par les accords d'evian
d'ailleurs pratiquement jamais appliqué
ici
ces images qui semblent déjà six
anciennes on pourrait dire presque rétro
lors des négociations entre la
délégation française conduite par louis
joxe et celle du fln que vous allez voir
dirigé par krim belkacem qui arrivait en
hélicoptère selon ces accords par
exemple aucune des possession de biens
français n'était prévu sans
indemnisation
à la bhl or la récente loi
d'indemnisation des rapatriés a été
votée sans aucune considération de 7
attendue caduque et complètement
dépassée alors comment imaginer un
nouveau cadre en créant des commissions
de haut niveau pour régler les problèmes
de la situation des deux communautés
vivent ici et là-bas en algérie est un
organisme de concertation économique à
condition que les mêmes dispositions
d'esprit préval de part et d'autre de la
méditerranée or il faut bien dire après
les récentes déclarations du ministre
algérien bouteflika sur l'attitude
adoptée par la france en afrique
il faut bien dire que le différend est
proprement politique pour l'instant
aucune réaction d'alger au propos
d'ouverture du président giscard
d'estaing le deuxième passage de
l'interview télévisée du président de
république qui mériterait d'être qui
mérite d'être repris ce soir c'est celui
qui concerne la défense nationale dans
le cadre d'un plan de désarmement
et oui les deux choses vont ensemble le
chef de l'état participera à la session
spéciale des nations unies sur le
désarmement en mai prochain à new york
il y défendra ses thèses pour un vrai
désarmement est un vrai contrôle qui ne
soit pas réservé aux deux
superpuissances d'où son idée d'une
agence internationale des satellites de
contrôle mais comme le désarmement
général et là ce n'est pas réaliste
l'expérience l'a montré il nous faut
conserver ce que le président a appelé
notre droit à la sécurité
c'est à dire une force nucléaire et un
armement dit conventionnel est là pour
monsieur giscard d'estaing il ya
déséquilibre le risque at il dit
et qu'à partir d'une crise politique
locale on en vienne à utiliser bon
d'abord les forces classiques le
maintien de l'ordre d'abord les forces
classiques ensuite ans et après à la fin
les moyens nucléaires
le détonateur c'est donc le risque d'un
déséquilibre dans les moyens
conventionnels les temps que les avions
c'est ça qu'il faut rétablir dans une
conférence européenne qu'il propose
pourquoi la france se sont elles en
infériorité
c'est là dessus que thierry de scitivaux
va nous apporter ses lumières
le risque principal en europe étant la
crise qui ne mettraient enjeux que des
moyens conventionnels
il convient que ceci soit à la mesure de
l'état qu'ils doivent défendre sur ce
plan nous sommes très en retard par
rapport à l'allemagne fédérale
non pas pour le nombre de soldats mais
pour les armements dont ils sont dotés
un gros effort sera donc entrepris pour
équiper nos unités des moyens classiques
qui leur permettront de compter en cas
de crise
pourquoi développer désarmement
classique alors que nous possédons
l'arme nucléaire dira-t-on tout
simplement parce que son utilisation
éventuelle et politique et qu'il ne
convient pas de faire de l' arme
tactique une super armes
conventionnelles la france va donc
développer considérablement ses moyens
de dissuasion d'ici 1990 en travaillant
sur la porte et la précision des
missiles sur le durcissement des ogives
à têtes multiples et sur la puissance
des charges
enfin il faudra que d'ici là dans le cas
de l'échec du désarmement
la france étudie d'autres types d'armes
telles que la bombe à neutrons ou le
missile de croisière
quelle vaste redoutable et même
angoissant problème que celui des armes
nucléaires et de leur prolifération la
france compte élevant ses usines de
retraitement par exemple au pakistan
estime prendre toutes les garanties pour
éviter cette prolifération
mais est ce qu'on s'est posé la question
de savoir s'ils possédaient d'uranium
ce n'était pas encore plus embarrassant
eh bien nous allons prendre ce soir le
cas de l'australie oui là bas tout au
bout on vient de découvrir la semaine
dernière un fantastique gisement qui
serait le plus important du monde
occidental il est de dix fois supérieur
en tout cas ce qu'on en attendait et
déjà il ya beaucoup de pays sur les
rangs pour acheter cet uranium notamment
les etats-unis la france l'allemagne
fédérale le japon cela peut représenter
d'énormes bénéfices pour l'australie
mais en même temps ça ne fait pas
l'unanimité chez les australiens
vous allez devoir dans un reportage de
régis faucon réalisé récemment une
chance nous trouvons la mairie kathleen
ferai de monza dans le nord de
l'australie n'est pas particulièrement
importantes particulièrement
impressionnante et pourtant elle est au
centre de l'actualité pourrait-on dire
ici en soi
car elle présente cette particularité
c'est la seule qui produisent
actuellement de l'uranium
or l'uranium est l'objet d'un véritable
débat national la question est de savoir
si l'on doit
oui ou non exploitées et exporter cet
uranium
l'australie est une véritable mine
j'allais dire dorn je pourrais dire
aussi d'argent de fer d'étain et cetera
elle revient dix sept fois dans la liste
des 20 plus importants producteurs
mondiaux
et en ce qui concerne l'uranium elle
possède le quart des réserves connues du
monde occidental
la tentation était donc grande
d'exploiter ce formidable filon mais le
gouvernement à trouver en travers de sa
route des écologistes des pacifistes des
intellectuels et même certains
syndicalistes opposé à l'exploitation et
surtout à l'exportation de l'uranium
chacun a ses arguments et le
gouvernement affirme pour sa part que
l'on ne vendra pas à n'importe qui
d'abord les pays intéressés devront être
signataire du traité de non
prolifération ou accepter des garanties
fixé par la commission internationale de
l'énergie atomique
nous leur demanderons de signer un
accord bilatéral avec nous pour
s'assurer qu'il respecte certaines
obligations et notamment qu'il ne
possède pas l'enrichissement de
l'uranium
sans nous avoir auparavant consulté de
façon à ce que ce soit de toute façon à
des fins pacifiques
le gouvernement avait fait une enquête
dont le résultat est clair il n'existe
actuellement aucune véritable garantie
beaucoup d'australiens s'inquiètent des
dangers du nucléaire en ce qui concerne
les déchets sécurité des réacteurs et le
développement d'uranium lui même les
risques pour les travailleurs et pour
l'environnement
bien sûr ils s'inquiètent aussi des
rapports entre le nucléaire utilisée à
des fins pacifiques est celui qui sert
des objectifs militaires
beaucoup de gens ne veulent pas que
l'uranium australien servent à faire des
banques
les manifestations souvent
spectaculaires n'ont apparemment pas
réussi à mobiliser l'opinion publique et
a impressionné le gouvernement qui a
décidé que les états d'âme d'une
minorité ne devait pas faire obstacle
aux bénéfices énormes notamment sur le
plan financier que le pays tout entier
pourrait tirer de l'exportation de
l'uranium ça facile réélection en
décembre dernier a conforté le
gouvernement libéral de malcolm fraser
dans son opinion pour le premier
ministre le débat est pratiquement clos
le gouvernement a pris une décision nous
continuerons à exploiter et exporter
l'uranium sous certaines conditions très
strictes
pour moi le résultat des élections
montre que notre politique est compris
nous sommes à 30 jours des législatives
le débat politique s'amplifient c'est
naturel mais souvent c'est le samedi et
le dimanche que se font les discours
important dans les circonscriptions
comme au plan national
du coup le vendredi est un jour où on
reprend son souffle il ya tout de même
des choses intéressantes dans le journal
des législatives de ce soir que vous
présente dominique laurens
la polémique pc ps poursuit par meeting
interposés georges marchais hier à
saint-brieuc la discipline républicaine
réclamée par le ps n'est qu'une
tentative d'usurper les voix des
travailleurs socialistes envisagent une
fois de plus d'exclus les communistes et
du gouvernement et il compte pour cela
sur le concours de monsieur giscard
d'estaing en amont le parti socialiste
repousse notre appel à l'union et il
demande aux électeurs de lui donner un
chèque en blanc
comment pourrait-on accepter une
prétention aussi exorbitants et comment
dans ces conditions ne pas se poser une
question
ras le parti socialiste veut-il vraiment
la victoire de la gauche
autre petite phrase à retenir jean
pierre chevènement noël je suis
convaincu que les désistements à gauche
s'effectueront convenablement et qu'un
accord interviendra au lendemain du
second tour entre communistes et
socialistes christian bilhac ministre du
travail à toulouse françois mitterrand
demande aux français de lui signer un
chèque en blanc
s'il se laissait abuser il s'apercevrait
le 20 mars que ce chèque était à l'ordre
du parti communiste inquiets des risques
de guerre civile après les élections
quel que soit le vainqueur
marcel dassault propose une réunion des
chefs de tous les partis de la majorité
comme de l'opposition pour mettre au
point sous l'autorité du premier
ministre
un programme d'union nationale
bataille de cils entre raymond barre et
les radicaux de gauche mrg protestent
contre le choix fait par le premier
ministre
de l'arbre comme symbole de sa campagne
nationale un symbole qui ressemble
étrangement estime-t-il
à celui des radicaux de gauche mille car
57 trains spéciaux 80 mille personnes
sont attendues demain à la porte de
pantin pour la fête du rpr le
rassemblement pour la république entend
démontrer sa puissance et sa force de
mobilisation
la cgt qui reste deux premiers syndicats
de france vient cependant d'enregistrer
une série de recul lors d'élections
professionnelles et cela au bénéfice de
plus tôt de sa concurrente la plus
directe la cfdt
c'est vrai par exemple à la sncf c'est
vrai chez renault vis à billes en cours
à la ratp au crédit du nord
la cgt qui reste souvent en tête est
même majoritaire en voix connaît tout de
même un recul sensible elle perd entre 3
et 10% des voix
ici je note que georges séguy ne se
plaint pas du renforcement de la cfdt je
dirais même qu'il se réjouit de ce qu'il
appelle l'évolution de la centrale
dirigée par edmond maire et il considère
que les thèses et les projets de la cfdt
se rapproche de celle de la cgt bien
c'est son opinion en tout cas cela dit
georges séguy est le seul des grands
leaders syndicaux à posséder
je m'exprime ainsi la double casquette
puisqu'il est membre du bureau politique
du parti communiste
d'une part et secrétaire général de la
cgt d'autre part ça peut poser des
problèmes
quand georges séguy dans un meeting à
gentilly appelé récemment à voter
communiste il parlait en tant que membre
du parti mais on pouvait aussi ne pas
faire la distinction avec sa fonction de
chef syndicaliste
comme il ya ambiguïté ya eu confusion la
cgt n'a pas donné de consigne de vote
mais on sait où sont les sentiments de
georges séguy d'ailleurs pour la cfdt ce
soir georges séguy utilise sa notoriété
syndicales pour appeler publiquement à
voter pour son parti politique et la
cfdt demande aux partis de gauche de se
prononcer dès maintenant pour le
désistement automatique en faveur du
candidat de gauche le mieux placé au
premier tour exactement c'est la
proposition des socialistes en fait à la
veille d'élections décisives les grands
responsables syndicaux sont sur un fil
de contradictions ils pèsent de tout
leur poids dans le sens des partis dont
ils se sentent proches mais sans pour
autant renier leur indépendance
syndicale inclus dans leur statut par
exemple force ouvrière indique qu'elle
ne donnera aucune consigne
de vote et va publier à un million deux
cent mille exemplaires un manifeste qui
condamne tout système d'encadrement et
de conditionnement revenons alors à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui au sein de la
cg de la cgt avec l'analyse de françois
go n'as tu pas de crise au sein de la
cgt mais quelques remous certes depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis la désunion de
la gauche des dirigeants ou des
militants cégétistes membres du parti
socialiste ont écrit à georges séguy
pour lui reprocher l'alignement la cgt
si on les thèses du parti communiste la
cgt sort de son rôle estime-t-il alors
elle prend des positions politiques
incompatibles avec l'exercice de sa
mission syndicale
il reproche aussi à la cgt d'avoir
fortunés jugement sévère sur le parti
socialiste
à présent d'avoir rencontré ses
dirigeants michel marsh lac du bureau
confédéral de la cgt répond nous ne
sommes pas du tout gêné par le fait que
des adhérents expriment des points de
vue qui conteste l'activité de la
direction confédérale
à la cgt on peut débattre de toutes les
questions c'est déjà arrivé en mai 1968
ou lors de la signature du programme
commun ou bien encore lors de l'élection
présidentielle fin de citation et les
dirigeants de la centrale syndicale
affirme que les lettres des
contestataires sont peu nombreuses
37 il précise également que l'exercice
de la démocratie syndicale peut et doit
être largement améliorée
désormais les colonnes de la presse cgt
seront ouvertes à l'expression
d'opinions divergentes nous allons
donner à ce débat une dimension
nationale dit encore michel marsh lac
au total sur les deux millions trois
cent mille adhérents que déclare la cgt
environ 700000 vote pour le parti
socialiste
lyon le juge d'aix a accepté cet
après-midi de recevoir les journalistes
pour leur raconter sa mésaventure son
enlèvement bien sûr le juge qui reste
sous surveillance médicale a réservé les
détails les plus importants de la sphère
aux enquêteurs à la police judiciaire et
la police s'intéresse surtout au milieu
des petits malfrats qui en enlevant le
magistrat aurait voulu venger dit on
l'un de leurs amis inculpé par le juge
en tout cas le premier ministre raymond
barre de passage aujourd'hui à lyon a
tenu à rencontrer le juger à lui exprimé
sa sympathie personnelle
peu après cette visite monsieur d'aix
rats
comptait son enlèvement à nos confrères
de fr3 je peux dire peu de choses sur
les circonstances de l'enlèvement étant
donné que j'ai eu une cagoule que je ne
peux pas indiquer le lieu où j'ai été
transportée et que les indications que
je peux fournir sont extrêmement
sommaire que vous vous adressez à quoi
vous pensez mais également les chiffres
il ya un effet surprise qui jouent à ce
moment là on sait pas si c'est pour
obtenir de l'argent ou si c'est dans un
autre but la réflexion elle vient après
coup et si vous pensez à aux vivres
l'eau a vu la simulation vidéo offre au
dessus ce nom lourd puis je note cette
réaction du maire de lyon le sénateur
francisque collomb qui viennent dire
c'est assez vivement
ce fait divers a servi une fois encore
de prétexte à certains parisiens et même
hélas à quelques élus extérieurs à la
région pour leur sempiternel campagne de
dénigrement de notre ville et de ses
habitants
oui la tentation est grande de répondre
par la colère ou le mépris ajoute
francisque collomb je dirai simplement
avec le maximum de sérénité que lyon
possède bien d'autres titres a occupé
devant la scène
nous l'avons déjà prouvé en plusieurs
occasions et c'est d'ailleurs vrai avec
vous jean claude narcy les autres
nouvelles de ce journal est un autre
fait divers cet après midi bull a une
sur scène deux malfaiteurs tués et un
autre arrêté le quatrième en fuite c'est
le bilan d'un hold up dans une banque
alerté par les passants et policiers
sont arrivés très vite sur les lieux
la voiture des truands a percuté les
véhicules en stationnement et s'est
trouvée bloquée alors qu'il tentait de
fuir une fusillade a éclaté
deux des malfaiteurs dont un grièvement
blessé se sont réfugiés dans un immeuble
voisin prenant en otages deux femmes et
un enfant deux heures après ils se sont
rendus aux hommes de la brigade antigang
le témoignage du commissaire leclerc qui
raconte comment les policiers ont donné
l'assaut à l'appartement pour libérer
les otages
ça nous intervenus dans les lieux les
malfaiteurs étaient réfugiés avec les
otages dans la salle de bain l'un d'eux
a pu être maîtrisé sans difficulté quant
à l'autre il était armé il a tiré un
coup de feu en direction des
fonctionnaires deux coups de feu en
direction des fonctionnaires
intervenants et nous sommes rendus
compte à ce moment-là qu'il était déjà
blessé qui avait une balle dans
l'abdomen
il s'agit de malfaiteurs qui sont
parfaitement connus de nos services il
s'agit celui qui avait été tuée lors de
la fusillade avec les forces de l'ordre
est a nommé noël que mon service avait
surveillé et filet pendant de nombreux
mois sur la banlieue sud de paris
celui qui a été retrouvé blessé dans la
baignoire est un numéro qu'a également
parfaitement connus de mes services
et quant à celui qui a été neutralisé
sans problème il s'agit d'un certain
aulas parfaitement connu également des
services de répression du banditisme
comment s'est passée l'entrée dans
l'appartement bien nous avons dû briser
la porte et a donné l'assaut
immédiatement les états unis ont adressé
une mise en garde à l'urss contre le
fait que toute offensive éthiopienne en
somalie pourrait transformer la corne de
l'afrique en une zone de tension
les etats unis la grande bretagne la
france l'allemagne et l'italie
à la suite de cette contre-offensive
éthiopienne et des paris soviétiques ont
fait savoir à moscou qu'il réexaminerait
l'embargo sur les armes décidé contre la
semaine liban les tirs ne cessent plus
depuis ce matin dans la banlieue de
beyrouth entre les milices conservatrice
et les troupes syriennes de la force
arabe de dissuasion qui encercle le
secteur avec des chars trois obus sont
même tombés près du camp de réfugiés de
challe ita sur le plan politique les
contacts se poursuivent pour tenter de
mettre un terme aux accrochages
sanglants qui aurait fait en trois jours
100 morts chez les syriens et 30 du côté
libanais et encore le bilan officiel n'a
pas encore été donné à deux ferries pour
alger et tunis pour demain le personnel
navigant a déposé un préavis de grève
les départs de marseille sont prévues
pour dimanche matin voici les deux
premières voitures du futur métro
d'atlanta en géorgie elles vont quitter
l'usiné de la société franco belge arrêt
messe près de valenciennes qui
construira en tout sans voiture le
nouveau métro d'atlanta fonctionnera le
25 décembre prochain
280 millions de francs c'est le plus
important contrat france et aux états
unis avec les falcons le marcel dassault
la société franco belge a déjà réalisé
les nouvelles rames du métro de
paris et les fameux train corail
l'aéroport de paris lui et chargée de la
construction de la nouvelle aérogare du
caire qui sera mise en service en 1981
le contrat d'un montant de 13 millions
de francs a été enlevé par l'aéroport de
paris face à une vingtaine de
concurrents du monde entier un
hélicoptère s'est écrasé cet après midi
en fin d'après midi au col de l'escrinet
dans l'ardèche entre privat et aubenas
on ignore s'il ya des victimes
11 millions de français c'est à dire un
sur cinq ont pris des vacances d'hiver
de septembre 65 16
ah mais 77 le tourisme d'hiver se porte
donc très bien c'est une des
constatations faites par les
professionnels du tourisme lors de
l'ouverture de la troisième semaine
mondiale du tourisme
c'était ça s'est passé ce matin
d'ailleurs et ça a été inaugurée par
monsieur jacques médecin 200 organismes
y participent tour operator transporteur
maritime ferroviaire routier et aérien
agents de voyages et enfin offices de
tourisme de france ou de l'étranger à
cette occasion pierre sauter le délégué
général d'air france a été choisie comme
la personnalité de l'année touristique
pour sa contribution à l'essor du
tourisme dans tous les domaines
promouvoir la chanson française dans le
monde c'est l'objectif du prix de la
jeune chanson auquel tf1 est intimement
associés créé par les échanges
francophone cette récompense concerne
tous les artistes d'expression française
pour 78 le prix a été attribué à jean
michel caradec un jeune chanteur breton
de grand talent et puis parmi les autres
lauréats pour les antilles par exemple
le groupe beausoleil bruce a en ce qui
est bien par suite du vent violent la
descente du camp d'art n'a pas pu avoir
lieu aujourd'hui sur la piste des
houches près de chamonix
si les conditions sont plus favorables
cette descente devrait avoir lieu demain
matin juste avant les deux manches du
slalom spécial messieurs en football les
joueurs professionnels du red star ne
joueront pas demain contre lille en
championnat de france
il n'apprécie pas du tout mais pas du
tout de ne pas avoir toucher leur paye
de décembre ni partiellement celle de
janvier
tabarly nous l'a annoncé cet après midi
ça maintenant officiel il va pouvoir
participer à la dernière manche de la
course autour du monde rio portsmouth la
fédération française de voile a obtenu
la requalification de peine bixis malgré
sa quille en uranium
eric tabarly quittera donc rio le 22
février prochain
et cela avec l'accord des organisateurs
britanniques ah ben ça c'est une bonne
elle bon le temps vous l'avez évoqué
avec le canard et bien c'est assez long
sur le temps non seulement le froid
s'installe mais encore il s'accentue et
le temps s'annonce médiocre pour les
départs en vacances de neige les
vacances scolaires de la zone à la
circulation est très perturbée par la
neige dans beaucoup d'endroits je vous
en donne deux exemples dans les pyrénées
il a fallu trois semaines d'efforts pour
débloquer puymorens et l'hospitalet où
les voitures ne circulaient plus où les
maisons s'écroulaient sous le poids de
la neige
d'autre part tout le massif dès cévennes
a connu des chutes de neige importantes
aujourd'hui même l'arrière-pays niçois
est transformé en paysage canadien en
quelque sorte vous allez voir ici la
route de sainte baume au plan d'aups 50
cm de neige tombés en une journée et ce
n'était pas arrivé depuis cinq ans et
quand ce n'est pas la neige c'est la
pluie battante qui perturbent la
circulation sur les autoroutes dans le
midi beaucoup de difficultés également
en bretagne
et là la neige et le verglas ont rendu
la circulation dangereuse dans les côtes
du rhône et dans le finistère dans les
côtes du nord pardon et dans le
finistère ce matin difficultés dans le
lyonnais également et puis j'apprends
que des centaines de véhicules ont été
bloqués dans les deux sèvres cet après
midi à l'entrée de bressuire
demain le temps est annoncée médiocre
bien sûr avec encore de la neige et du
verglas dans l'intérieur les
précipitations seront abondantes surtout
du limousin et du nord aux frontières du
nord et du nord-est mais finalement il y
aura de la neige partout parfois
accompagnées d'orages près de la
méditerranée
les vents seront assez forts et même
fort près des côtes et dimanche ça
continuera un temps à rester au lit sauf
dans le midi et près de l'atlantique où
ça doit tout de même s'améliorer c'est
ce qu'on nous dit c'est ce que nous dit
la météo
et pourtant nous ne devrions pas nous
plaindre excessivement si nous prenions
la peine de comparer notre situation à
celle des habitants du nord des etats
unis new york par exemple est
complètement enlisée depuis plus d'une
semaine c'est la tempête sur la ville
c'est la paralysie et pourtant les new
yorkais ont l'habitude des hivers rudes
on prend des précautions mais ça n'a pas
suffi cette fois ci comme l'a constaté
notre correspondant permanent dominique
mon berger new york
un journaliste dans la tempête lundi la
neige tombe depuis le milieu de la nuit
précédente
à 4 heures le centre en l'aspect d'une
ville morte où ne circulent plus que
quelques autobus et quelques taxis quand
tout d'un coup le chutes de neige
tourner au blizzard
le vent pousse des pointes à 90 km/heure
sur 30 cm de neige il était difficile de
rouler il devient presque impossible de
marcher
le soir les hôtels les gares et les
aéroports sont bondés de voyageurs qui
n'ont pu quitter la ville on n'a pas
encore vu le pire mardi
la couche de neige atteint 60 cm au
centre de la ville en banlieue des
congères haute parfois de deux mètres
sont formés à proximité des maisons
contre les voitures au milieu des rues
on apprend qu'il ya eu plusieurs morts
le nombre des décès montera jusqu'à 16
banlieusards égaré la tempête ou
vieillards intoxiquées dans des maisons
trop froide par des chauffages d'appoint
mal réglé dans les faubourgs des groupes
de volontaires s'organisent pour venir
au secours des plus menacé mercredi
la tempête a cessé le soleil brille par
-8 degrés après 52 heures de fermeture
des trois aéroports le trafic aérien
reprend et l'on mesure l'ampleur de la
catastrophe
le gouverneur de l'état demande au
président carter de proclamer new york
john de désastre 4000 voitures
abandonnées sur des autoroutes
totalement impraticable parfois portes
ouvertes par des conducteurs et perdu
devant chercher leur chemin dans la
tempête au moins 250 millions de francs
de dommages
la ville de new york déjà mal en point
financièrement n'avait pas besoin de
cela
au soir du troisième jour l'activité
dans le centre de la ville revient peu à
peu à la normale en banlieue en revanche
il faudra beaucoup plus de temps pour
éliminer les dernières traces de la
tempête d'une tempête qui sera resté
dans l'esprit de beaucoup comme une
catastrophe dans l'esprit d'autres en
revanche comme une surprise étonnante
dans une ville où l'on peut très bien se
faire attaquer sans que les passants se
détournent le moins du monde de leur
chemin on a pu assister à des scènes
d'un dévouement et d'une générosité
incroyable tf1
fuir à new york ça prend tout de suite
une tempête de neige des proportions
extraordinaires
et puis attendez ce n'est peut-être pas
terminée on annonce une nouvelle tempête
sur new york aujourd'hui voilà bonne
soirée à tous au nom de toute l'équipe
de tf1 actualité dernier journal
dominique baudis vers 23h20 merci